sometime next week the US Air Force will
launch a small unmanned space plane into
orbit the x-37b orbital test vehicle
it's about one-fifth the size of the
Space Shuttle it can partially fly
itself and it lands like a plane which
makes it reusable that's about the
extent of what we know because the Air
Force keeps the space drones missions
top-secret the x-37b has flown three
missions so far and theories about what
exactly it's testing up there range from
orbital surveillance technologies to
futuristic weapon systems this upcoming
fourth mission is a little less
mysterious the Air Force has revealed
that it will be testing out a new super
efficient propulsion system it'll also
be carrying materials samples from NASA
see how well they hold up in the harsh
environment of space the x-37b is set to
launch on Wednesday May 20th from Cape
Canaveral Air Force Station how long
will this mission last and supposedly
the Air Force hasn't decided yet
in any event civilians should expect
radio silence from the x-37b until it
returns to earth probably months from
now
you